70 years ago
i was in high school
almost a third as long as the country
has been around
and when i was in high school
i really only had two things on my mind
girls and cars
and
and it wasn't doing very well with girls
so we'll talk about cars
but let's just imagine
that when we finish i'm going to let
each one of you pick out the car of your
choice sounds good doesn't it
uh pick it out any color
you name it it'll be tied up with a bow
and it'll be at your house tomorrow
and you say well what's the catch
and the catch is
that it's the only car you're going to
get in your lifetime
now what are you going to do
knowing that that's the only car
you're ever going to have and you love
that car
you're going to take care of it like you
cannot believe
now what i'd like to suggest
you're not going to get only one car in
your lifetime
but you're going to get one body and one
mind
and that's all you're going to get
and that body and mind
feels terrific now
but it has to last you a lifetime
want to be happy build a life not just a
business hey it's evan carl michael and
this channel is created to help you
overcome the number one challenge that
is holding you back a lack of belief in
yourself you watch these videos because
you know there's something more inside
you too you've got michael jordan level
genius at something so today let's live
your best believe life and get some
amazing insights from warren buffett
[Music]
rule number two never give up you
rejected by harvard you went to columbia
business school and then you met the man
who you really idolized ben graham and
when you took his class was he as great
as you had thought he was going to be he
really was he only he only taught
one semester one class i mean he came up
from wall street and taught this class
uh that's the reason i went to columbia
and uh
he
i knew what he i knew i'd already read
all the books and everything so i but it
was inspirational just to be around him
and i i it made a real difference in my
life so when you um
graduated you wanted to go work for him
and his firm and then he rejected you uh
for an interesting reason uh in those
days i understand that there were jewish
firms and non-jewish firms and his was a
jewish firm and you weren't jewish so he
said because you weren't jewish he
didn't hire you is that right that's
true he's and i i was ready to convert
believe me
i i think they might have felt a little
phony at the time so i uh but it was it
was true that uh there were very few
firms in wall street that would hire
jews at that time and ben only employed
five or six people but he told me to the
extent that they had
were able to employ five or six people
they really felt that the jews could not
get into
most jobs in wall street and that they
they were going to employ only jews you
moved back for a while to um
nebraska but then he ultimately changed
his mind and you went to work for ben
graham i kept pestering him yeah i made
a real best of myself rule number three
choose love over wealth how would you
define true success
well i've i've said many times that that
if you get to be
65 or 70
and later and and the people that you
want to have love you actually do love
you
you're a success i've never seen anybody
that reaches that age i mean i'm not
talking about somebody that's in extreme
poverty or pain or something but i've
never seen anybody that if they have a
lot of people
that love them that is other than happy
and i've seen some very very wealthy
people that they give testimonial
dinners too and name schools after and
everything nobody nobody loves them rule
number four be determined to succeed i
would
i would like to tell you of
two women
that each sold the business
to berkshire hathaway
uh to me actually for many many many
millions of dollars
both of them started with twenty five
hundred dollars by a coincidence was the
exact same amount it was everything they
had in the world
and one of them
was a woman
who landed in seattle in 1917
couldn't speak a word of english
had a tag around her neck
the tag said
uh
fort dodge iowa
the red cross
got her to fort dodge where she was
reunited with her husband who had come
to the country a couple of years earlier
and she lived in fort dodge for two
years
and as she put it
she felt like a dummy
she couldn't pick up the language she
couldn't learn a word
and so she decided she and her husband
decided
to move to omaha
so they came to omaha
in 1919
and there she found a
small colony of russian jews so she
started feeling more at home
and then as her oldest daughter went to
school
she would come home this daughter
francis
and she would teach her mother the words
she learned in school that day
and this woman rose blumpkin
spent 20 years
saving money
bringing first her siblings over
her mother and father
50 at a time she sold used clothing to
do it
she had four children during this period
and by 1937 after 20 years
she'd save 2 500
she went to chicago
and she bought what she could have
furniture her dream had always been to
open
a furniture store
and this woman without who had never
gone to school one day in her life
with twenty five hundred dollars
but with the same spirit that the people
in this room had
about having a dream
and working to accomplish that dream
she built a business
which she
sold to me in 1983 for
60 million dollars approximately in
which
which did a billion and a half dollars
worth of business last year
[Applause]
the fourth generation is working in that
business
this woman rose blumpkin
lived
while she she worked for me until she
was 103
and
then she
said then she retired and she died the
next year which is a lesson to all of
berkshire's managers that
premature retirement you know nothing
you can't tell what's going to happen
but mrs b
with her 2500
one further fact about her
she could not read or write
and she went into a furniture business
and she didn't bring anything in unique
in furniture but she brought a
determination to succeed
she knew she could outwork anyone else
she knew she cared about her customers
she worked at very low gross margins but
she built this incredible business rule
number five invest in yourself by far
the best investment you can make is in
yourself i mean that for example
communication skills i tell the students
that come that
they're going to
graduate schools and
business and they're learning all these
complicated formulas and all that if
they just learn to communicate better
and both in writing and in person they
increase their value at least fifty
percent no i mean
if you can't communicate somebody says
you know it's like winking at a girl in
the dark nothing happens you know
basically and and you have to be able to
get
get both your ideas and uh
and that's
that's relatively easy i did it myself
with the dale carnegie of course some
people wish i'd taken a shorter course
now in terms of my talking later on but
it
it's just hugely important and you if
you invest in yourself nobody can take
it away from you rule number six define
your circle of competence i have an
old-fashioned belief that i can
only should expect to make money and
things that i understand and when i say
understand i don't mean to understand
you know what the product does or
anything like that
i mean understand what the economics of
the business are likely to look at look
like 10 years from now or 20 years from
now
i know in general
what the economics will say wrigley
chewing gum will look like 10 years from
now
the internet isn't going to change the
way people chew gum
it isn't going to change which gum they
chew
you know if you own the chewing gum
market
in a big way and you've got double mint
and spearmint and juicy fruit
those brands will be there 10 years from
now so i can't pinpoint exactly what the
numbers are going to look like on
wrigley but i'm not going to be way off
if i try to look forward on something
like that
that evaluating that company is within
what i call my circle of competence i
understand
what they do i understand the economics
of it i understand the competitive
aspects of the business figuring out the
economic consequences
tv
i think there's i don't know 20 25
million cents a year sold in the united
states i don't think there's one of them
made in the united states anymore i mean
you'd say tv set manufacturer what a
wonderful business i
everybody and nobody had a tv in 1950
that are there about 45 to 50.
everybody has multiple sets now
but nobody in the united states has made
any real money making the sense they're
all out of business you know the magna
boxes the rca's all of those companies
radio was the equivalent of the 20 over
500 companies making radios in the 1920s
again i don't think there's a
u.s radio manufacturer at the present
time but coca-cola you know i was in
1884 jacob's pharmacy or whatever fellow
comes up with something a lot of copiers
over the years
but now you've got a company that is
selling
roughly 1.1 billion eight ounce servings
of its product not all cokes bright and
some others
daily throughout the world
117 years later so understanding
the economic characteristics of a
business is different than predicting
the fact that an industry is going to do
wonderfully so when i look at the
internet
businesses or i look at tech messages i
say this is a marvelous thing and i love
to play around with the computer and it
now i order my books from amazon and all
kinds of things but i don't know who's
going to win
unless i know who's going to win
i'm not interested in investing i'll
just play around on the computer and
defining your circle of competence is
the most important aspect of investing
it's not how important how large your
circle is you don't have to be an expert
on everything
but knowing where the perimeter of that
circle of what you know and what you
don't know is and staying inside of it
is all important
tom watson senior who started ibm
said in his book he said
i'm no genius he said but i'm smart in
spots and i stay around those spots
and you know that is the key
so if i understand a few things and i
stick in that arena i'll do okay
and if i don't understand something but
i get all excited about it because my
neighbors are talking about stocks are
going up and everything
they start fooling around someplace else
eventually i'll get cream and i should
rule number seven the light customers
henry ford as you may know
failed twice before he started the
ford motor company in 1903 i mean
the
the test isn't whether you get the
greatest
business idea in the world the first
time out the test is whether you keep
learning as you go along
what your strengths are and what you can
do for your customers what you can bring
especially to the party
and to do that you need
a
genuine
a genuine desire day and
day out
to
delight the customer
i've never i've never seen a business
and i've seen
a lot of businesses but i've never seen
one that
delights the customer
that
that doesn't succeed i mean what you
want is that customer the next day when
they think do i want to rent a car
or do i want to buy some furniture
what goes through their mind
you know it's the place where they've
had a great experience um i don't know
what
i paid for this
type actually probably if somebody gave
it to me but for the purposes of the
speech i will
say i i have no idea but what i or the
shirt i'm wearing others but i do know i
will remember
how i was treated
when i bought it i mean you long forget
about
the price
but you never forget
whether you had a good experience or a
poor experience
uh
with the purchase experience rule number
eight have the right framework i was
wondering if you have any stock tips for
any of the students you know who are all
trying to
uh make make a little living
i didn't think they taught that at
georgetown
they
now the
the best the best investment i ever met
well
i i bought a book in 1949 by a fellow
named ben graham called the intelligent
investor i i don't remember what i paid
but aside from what i paid for my two
marriage licenses that was the best
investment i ever made
and
it's very important to have the right
framework you need
you need
you need to have an approach to
investing
that sound and
graham's approach is is simple
uh but some people
uh
adopt to it and and
which i did immediately and and most
people don't
but if you have the right philosophy
you will find opportunities
uh as you go through the next 20 30 40
50 years and and frankly you're most
likely to find them uh
when in periods like five years ago when
we were having the panic i mean
stocks
sell at silly prices from time to time
most stocks at one time or another sell
at very silly prices
and
it doesn't take a high iq to figure out
that they're cheap but it does take a
temperament that's willing to step up
and actually act
i tell people if they're going in the
investment business
if you've got 160 iq
sell 30 points to somebody else because
you won't need it i mean that
that
it yeah i mean i figured out very early
you don't have to be that smart of this
business which is fortunate but you do
have to have the right temperament and
you have to be able to ignore
what other people are saying and and
simply look at the facts and decide
is this stock which is selling it x
worth 2x and occasionally you'll find
things like that and if when you don't
find them you don't do anything so
that's my
generalized stock tip no names rule
number nine read biographies i should
mention one thing about reading
uh
it was at the library here at columbia
that i wish i spent probably more time
than any other uh student
i i lived there practically but
you know i pulled the book out there
happened to be who's an american that
told me something about my professor
benjamin graham and then i looked up and
i went to the library and i said i want
to look learn more about this because i
learned this over here
that changed my whole life you know we
own geico now
because of
that librarian directing me
to some other book and then following
through on that
it's the chance i i
i read about one-fifth the pace the bill
does but i still spend five or six hours
a day reading i mean it just you can
learn so much i particularly love
biography just
you know to be able
to live the lives of these people that
have been extorted and seeing so
extraordinary the lessons and the you
know the discouragements they face just
everything about it so i did you can't
get enough of reading number 10 conquer
your fears
somebody once said that the chains of
habit
are too light to be felt until they're
too heavy to be broken
i had been terrified of public speaking
i couldn't do it i'd throw up
and i knew if i didn't cure it then
i never cured it
and so i saw an ad in the paper for the
dale carnegie course
which worked on developing your ability
to speak in public
and i went down there
a good smile has the same effect as a
puppy's tail on a puppy they made us do
all these crazy things to get out of
ourselves and so we stood on tables and
did all kinds of things
[Music]
[Applause]
if i hadn't have done that
my whole life would have been different
so in my office
you will not see the degree i got from
the university of nebraska you'll not
see the master's degree i got from
columbia university but you'll see the
little award certificate i got from the
dale carnegie course rule number 11 do
what you love
how would you advise people who aren't
necessarily going into a career field in
which you would make a
large base salary such as like medicine
or
something like that maybe
performing arts or
music
how would you advise us to keep up
financially with the rest of the world
well
it is true
that a market system
uh
[Music]
does not pay as well in some in some
activities as
as might seem appropriate
for the importance of those activities
the society just take teaching for
example i mean teaching does not pay
well
and what could be more important i mean
you know you've got to be as
as interested in who you're
the teachers of your children are as who
your accountant is or you know uh
whatever or who's winning the
heavyweight title of the world or that
sort of thing but but it doesn't it
doesn't pay well and and
it's a fundamental choice
uh whether you're going to go into
something that for many people it'd be
it'd be a fundamental choice whether
you're going to go into something you
love or something to to try and make a
lot of money i think that
generally it pays to go with what you
love and
i think that
it's very hard to find people
when they get to be my age
who say they're on that they've loved
what they've done all their life and
feel was very worthwhile
but they're terribly sad they made that
choice because they didn't make a lot of
money i i don't think anybody's ever
ever said that to me that they wish
they'd gone into something else where
they were uncomfortable doing it or
didn't enjoy it didn't feel very
productive but made a lot of money so i
don't think you'll find
that so i would i would i would go to
work
i would go to work
in whatever turns you on it may turn out
that it will be more profitable than
than you can think but
almost everybody here will make
enough money unless they get some
terrible habits along the way
to do reasonably well and and doing
reasonably well in this country
really is
is uh is pretty darn good i mean
it is
it's not necessary to have
huge amounts of money in order enjoy
yourself i enjoyed myself when i was at
my ten thousand dollars and i live in
the same house that i lived in when i
was making it when i had about that i
bought it 41 years ago i like the house
then i like the house now i mean
if you think about it
if you have a reasonable job
you'll be eating at mcdonald's and i'll
be eating a mcdonald's so we're we're to
push on on on food i mean you know in
fact i hope it's dairy queen actually
and maybe
and if you come to dairy queen you'll
see me and you can order anything on the
menu i can order and we both can afford
it
uh
you know you'll you'll wear the same
clothes i wear i'll pay more for my
suits but as soon as i put them on they
look cheap on me so we'll look about the
same and
uh
we'll both live in the same kind of
houses i live in that house from 41
years ago and it's it's it's it's warm
in winter and it's cool in summer and
it's comfortable
and you'll live in a house that's that's
similar and
and what difference does it make if you
have 50 more rooms or you know guest
houses are all at it you know it'll
probably just bring you problems i mean
you have to worry about the about the
greenskeeper or something when you get
through so i i i have been in the houses
of people
uh where the houses are worth
um oh probably 200 times
what my house is worth and i would not
be any happier in those houses at all in
fact i'd be less happy i just have one
more thing to
to worry about and you know the
dozens of people around the place and
people quitting and people stealing from
you and all kinds of things to hell with
it yeah uh
we drive we'll drive the same kind of
car in fact you'll probably drive a
better car i drive a car it's about
eight years old i don't know what it's
worth now but it gets me around fine i
mean i i'm perfectly happy we'll watch
we'll watch the same television you know
we'll work on the same computer pretty
much the only difference will be
how we travel long distances you know
i will
fly in a plane that's
more comfortable than
than flying southwest airlines or
something and which i've got nothing
against but that's the one real big
difference and other than that i do what
i like every day i hope you you'll do
what you like every day to do and i work
with nice people i hope you work with
nice people
and there's 24 hours in the day and
those are where the hours go so
great wealth
uh
is
the tiniest bit different
in a real sense than having just a
decent
a decent income and
and to trade
a decent income
and something you love doing and
something where you feel worthwhile
doing it
for
huge wealth where you trade off a lot of
your principles
uh would be a terrible mistake and rule
number 12 the last one before some very
special bonus clips is have discipline
you don't need 150 iq to do what i do
thank god you know well you don't need
140 you know 135 you may need 115 or
something like that and
and but you do need discipline
you have to wait until you see the fat
pitch to swing at
because investing is a no-call strike
game you know if i were a baseball
player and i only like pitches
two inches above my navel
you know some guy could learn that and
he could pitch me you know three or four
inches below that and i get called out
on strikes because i never find a pitch
i like
you can get call out on strikes in
baseball
you have to you have to swing at pitches
that you you don't even necessarily like
particularly after the count gets to two
strikes
in business
you don't have to swing at anything you
can sit there and
the paper says general motors at 68 or
it says general electric at 115 or so
general dynamics at 63.
and if you don't like those prices you
don't have to swing you can wait there
day after day after day after day and
there are no called strikes now when you
swing when you decide to buy something
then you know if you swing and miss it's
a strike but
it's a marvelous game to be in because
there are no called strikes and you can
simply wait for that one time
in a month or six months or a year or
two or three years when you really know
what you're doing where you like the
price or you like the people running the
business
and then you swing and you only need a
few swings in your lifetime
there's a company here in
in washington called geico you know and
i i first got exposed to that in 1950 i
was
i was 20 years i was 19 years old
it was 51 i'm sorry i was 20 years old
and
i came down here and and i came down on
a saturday
because i learned that my
professor who i worshipped at columbia
named ben graham was the chairman i got
down here and the door was locked when i
went to the building because it was
saturday and i pounded on the door and
some janitor let me in and a marvelous
fellow named lauren davidson
spent four hours with me teaching me all
about insurance and he
he helped me so much in life but you're
going to get
you're going to get helped by some
wonderful people in life it's a great
thing to to remember later on when you
be my age that you know all the help
you've received from different people
because
nobody does it alone obama got in
trouble when he said that in the
campaign that you know nobody does it by
themselves nobody does do it by
themselves we all sit
in the shade of trees that were planted
by others so it's obligatory i think to
plant a few trees ourselves if we've had
good luck uh
it's
it's been a great ride but it's not over
all of you in this room
have the brains to do extremely well in
life
you've all got the energy to do
extremely well in life and then the
question is how do you apply it
if you've got a 200 horsepower motor you
get 200 horsepower out of it do you get
your full
potential or do you get 100 horsepower
or 50 horsepower
now there's two things that can
hold you back
in getting the full horsepower out of
your your engine whatever it may be all
of you have big enough engines
and one of those is a lack of education
but that probably isn't going to happen
to very many people in this room if you
did have a lack of education if you
didn't have a chance to get a decent
education in life it wouldn't make any
difference what that potential was
because you'd never unlock it
but the second most important thing
and equally as important
is in terms of the habits that you
develop in terms of what you do with
yourself
when we
hire people we look for three qualities
we look for integrity we look for
intelligence and we look for energy
but if they don't have the first one
integrity the other two will kill you
because if you're hiring somebody
without integrity you really want to be
dumb and lazy don't you i mean you know
last thing in the world you want forms
to be smart and energetic so smart and
energetic only goes with integrity
but the nice thing about
[Music]
you know you make your own decision on
that you can't change
your iq or how far you control football
or how high you can jump or the color of
your hair very easily but you can
elect
to have integrity that matches anybody
else's and if you match that
with intelligence which you have and
energy which you have
[Music]
you will get an extraordinary result and
you'd be very foolish to sell me ten
percent of yourself for fifty thousand
on the other hand
if you don't match it with that your
potential will in a significant part go
unused how would you advise people who
aren't necessarily going into a career
field in which you would make a
large base salary such as like medicine
or
something like that maybe
performing arts or
music how would you advise us to
keep up financially with the rest of the
world
well
it is true
that a market system
uh
does not pay as well in some in some
activities as
as might seem appropriate
for the importance of those activities
the society just take teaching for
example i mean teaching does not pay
well
and what could be more important i mean
you know you've got to be as as
interested in who you're
the teachers of your children are as who
your accountant is or you know whatever
or who's winning the heavyweight title
of the world or that sort of thing but
but it doesn't it doesn't pay well and
and
it's a fundamental choice
uh whether you're going to go into
something that for many people it'd be
it'd be a fundamental choice whether
you're going to go into something you
love or something to to try and make a
lot of money i think that
generally it pays to go with what you
love and
i think that
it's very hard to find people
when they get to be my age
who say they're on that they've loved
what they've done all their life and
feel was very worthwhile
but they're terribly sad they made that
choice because they didn't make a lot of
money i i don't think anybody's ever
ever said that to me that they wish
they'd gone into something else where
they were uncomfortable doing it or
didn't enjoy it didn't feel very
productive but made a lot of money so i
don't think you'll find that so i would
i would i would go to work
i would go to work
in whatever turns you on
it may turn out that it'll it'll be more
profitable than than you can think but
almost everybody here will make
enough money unless they get some
terrible habits along the way
to do reasonably well and and doing
reasonably well in this country
really is
is uh is pretty darn good i mean
it is
it's not necessary to have
huge amounts of money in order enjoy
yourself i enjoyed myself when i was had
my ten thousand dollars and i live in
the same house that i lived in when i
was making it but when i had about that
i bought it 41 years ago i like the
house then i like the house now i mean
if you think about it
if you have a reasonable job
you'll be eating at mcdonald's and i'll
be eating a mcdonald's so we're we're to
push on on on food i mean you know in
fact i hope it's dairy queen actually
and maybe
and if you come to dairy queen you'll
see me and you can order anything on the
menu i can order we both can afford it
you know you'll you'll wear the same
clothes i wear i'll pay more for my
suits but as soon as i put them on they
look cheap on me so we'll look about the
same and
we'll both live in the same kind of
houses i live in that house from 41
years ago and it's it's it's warm in
winter and it's cool in summer and it's
comfortable
and you'll live in a house that's that's
similar and and what difference does it
make if you have 50 more rooms or you
know guest houses or all that
you know it'll probably just bring you
problems i mean you have to worry about
the about the greenskeeper or something
when you get through so i i i have been
in the houses of people
where the houses are worth um
oh probably 200 times
uh what my house is worth and i would
not be any happier in those houses at
all in fact i'd be less happy i just
have one more thing
to worry about and you know the
dozens of people around the place and
people quitting and people stealing from
you and all kinds of things to hell with
it yeah uh
we drive we'll drive the same kind of
car in fact you'll probably drive a
better car i drive our cars about eight
years old i don't know what it's worth
now but it gets me around fine i mean
i'm perfectly happy we'll watch
we'll watch the same television you know
we'll we'll work on the same computer
pretty much the only difference will be
how we travel long distances you know
i will
fly in a plane that's more comfortable
than
than flying southwest airlines or
something which i've got nothing against
but that's the one real big difference
and other than that i do what i like
every day i hope you you'll do what you
like every day to do and i work with
nice people i hope you work with nice
people uh
and that's there's 24 hours in the day
and those are where the hours go so
great wealth
uh
is
the tiniest bit different
in a real sense than having just a
decent
a decent income and
and to trade
a decent income
and something you love doing and
something where you feel worthwhile
doing it
for
huge wealth where you trade off a lot of
your principles
uh would be a terrible mistake
i was wondering if you have any stock
tips for any of the students you know
we're all trying to
uh make make a little living i didn't
think they taught that at georgetown
they
now the
the best the best investment i ever met
well
i i bought a book in 1949 by a fellow
named ben graham called the intelligent
investor i i don't remember what i paid
but aside from what i paid for my two
marriage licenses that was the best
investment i ever made
and uh
it's very important to have the right
framework you need
you need
you need to have an approach to
investing
that sound and
graham's approach is is simple
but some people
adopt to it and and
which i did immediately and and most
people don't
um but if you have the right philosophy
you will find opportunities
uh as you go through the next 20 30 40
50 years and and frankly you're most
likely to find them uh
when in periods like five years ago when
we were having the panic i mean that
uh
stocks
sell at silly prices from time to time
most stocks at one time or another sell
at very silly prices
and
it doesn't take a high iq to figure out
that they're cheap but it does take a
temperament that's willing to step up
and actually act
i tell people if they're going in the
investment business
if you've got 160 iq
sell 30 points to somebody else because
you won't need it i mean that
i mean i figured out very early you
don't have to be that smart of this
business which is fortunate but you do
have to have the right temperament and
you have to be able to ignore
what other people are saying and and
simply look at the facts and decide
is this stock which is selling it x
worth 2x and occasionally you'll find
things like that and if when you don't
find if you don't do anything so
that's my
generalized stock tip no name well in
uh the washington post company had gone
public in 1971 right about the pentagon
papers type time but in 73
uh the nixon administration
uh
was through bibi rebozo who was a palo
nixon's they were challenging uh the
licenses of two of the florida
television stations the post owned so
the stock went from
37 down to 16. now at 16 there were
about 5 million shares outstanding so
the whole washington post company was
selling for 80 million dollars and that
included a newspaper four big tv
stations newsweek you know and some
other assets and no debt to speak of so
the washington post company which was
intrinsically worth four or five hundred
million dollars
was selling for about 80 million in the
market we bought most of our stock at
about the equivalent of 100 million in
the market and and it was it was
ridiculous i mean you had a business
that unquestionably was worth four or
five times what it was selling for and
nixon wasn't going to put them out of
business when you're doing these
analyses then and now do you have
computers that help you or how did you
actually read all what do you guys get
written materials or how did you in
those days get the materials to read
about the washington post and how do you
do it today well
same pretty much the same way except
there's fewer opportunities now but
i met bob woodward back and and and he'd
just come out with all the president
savannah and all of a sudden as a below
30 years of age he was getting quite
wealthy and we had we had
breakfast or lunch over at the madison
hotel he said what do i do with this
money and i said i said investing is
just about assigning yourself the right
story i said imagine ben bradley this
morning said to you what is the
washington post company worth what would
you do if you have to write the story in
a month you'd go out and interview tv
brokers and newspaper brokers and the
owners and you'd try and value each
asset i said that's what i do i assign
myself the right story and it's it's
nothing more than that now there's some
stories i can't write if you ask me to
write a story on you know what is some
glamorous but non-profit making business
worth i don't know how to write that
story but if you ask me to write a story
on what is potomac electric power worth
or something like that i can write the
story and that's what i'm doing every
day i'm assigning myself a story and
then i go out everything you do learn is
cumulative i mean that doesn't mean that
industries stay good forever or
businesses stay good forever but but
learning to think about business models
what i learned at 20 is useful to me now
what i learned at 25 is useful to me now
and so
it's not it's not so it's not a field
that
changes
dramatically in terms of the underlying
principles it's like physics i mean
there's underlying principles now
they're doing all kinds of things with
physics they weren't doing 50 years ago
but
but if you know the if you've got the
principles if you know what makes a good
business if you know what makes a good
manager you know if you know what makes
a a good product
uh
and you learn that in one business you
can there is some transference
to other businesses as you go along and
you learn what things you you're not
going to understand i mean
knowing what to leave out is just as
important as knowing what to focus on
and
uh
i don't think i can win every game you
know somebody said how do you beat bobby
fischer you play him any game except
chassis so i don't play bobby fischer
chess
and that's there's a lot of value to
learning that over time and and learning
what you're good at and what you're not
good at you will
move in the direction of the people that
you associate with so i
it's important to associate with people
that are better than yourself and
actually the most important decision
many of you make not all of you will be
the spouse you're choosing
and uh you really
you want to associate with people who
are the kind of person you'd like to be
you'll you'll move in that direction and
the most important person by far
in that respect is your spouse
i can't overemphasize how important that
is and you're right
the friends you have
uh
they will form you as you go
through life and
uh
make some good friends keep them for the
rest of your life but have them be
people that you admire as well as like
them over the years i've developed a
better understanding of human nature
i can learn a lot about investments out
of a book but i don't think you can
learn as much about human beings
you really need some experiences and i'm
wiser in that respect than i was
40 or 50 years ago even though
i can't rattle off numbers the same way
i used to be able to i have an
old-fashioned belief that i can
only should expect to make money and
things that i understand and when i say
understand i don't mean to understand
you know what the product does or
anything like that
i mean understand what the economics of
the business are likely to look at look
like 10 years from now or 20 years from
now
i know in general
what the economics of say wrigley
chewing gum will look like 10 years from
now
the internet isn't going to change the
way people chew gum
it isn't going to change which gum they
chew
you know if you own the chewing gum
market
in a big way
and you've got double mint and spearmint
and juicy fruit
those brands will be there 10 years from
now so i can't pinpoint exactly
what the numbers are going to look like
on wrigley but i'm not going to be way
off if i try to look forward on
something like that
that evaluating that company is within
what i call my circle of competence i
understand
what they do i understand the economics
of it i understand the competitive
aspects of the business figuring out the
economic consequences
tv
i think there's i don't know 20 25
million cents a year sold in the united
states i don't think there's one of them
made in the united states anymore i mean
you'd say tv set manufacturer what a
wonderful business i tr everybody and
nobody had a tv in 1950
they're about 45 to 50.
everybody has multiple sets now
but nobody in the united states has made
any real money making the sense that
they're all out of business you know the
magna boxes the rca's all of those
companies radio was the equivalent of
the 20 over 500 companies making radios
in the 1920s again i don't think there's
a
u.s radio manufacturer at the present
time
but coca-cola you know
i was at 1884 jacob's pharmacy or
whatever and fellow comes up with
something a lot of copiers over the
years
but now you've got a company that
is selling
roughly 1.1 billion eight ounce servings
of its product not all cokes bright and
some others
daily throughout the world
117 years later so understanding
the economic characteristics of a
business is different than predicting
the fact that an industry is going to do
wonderfully so when i look at the
internet
businesses or i look at tech messages i
say this is a marvelous thing and i love
to play around with the computer and it
now i order my books from amazon and all
kinds of things but i don't know who's
going to win
unless i know who's going to win
i'm not interested in investing i'll
just play around on the computer and
defining your circle of competence is
the most important aspect of investing
it's not how important how large your
circle is you don't have to be an expert
on everything
but knowing where the perimeter of that
circle of what you know and what you
don't know is and staying inside of it
is all important
tom watson senior who started ibm
said in his book he said
i'm no genius he said but i'm smart in
spots and i stay around those spots
and you know that is the key uh so if i
understand a few things and i stick in
that arena i'll do okay
and if i don't understand something but
i get all excited about it because my
neighbors are talking about stocks are
going up and everything
they start fooling around someplace else
eventually i'll get cream and i should
if you look around the world
at the people that
succeed and the people that other people
want to work with the natural leaders it
isn't because they have the highest iq
or they can kick a football the furthest
or anything like that they're they're
people that you want to work with i mean
i've got a wonderful friend named tom
murphy i know i would do anything for
him you know he's never going to ask me
to do it but i mean i want it but i want
to do it i mean i want to do it i mean
he's done so many things for me and then
and you know i you know you don't have
to pay me to do it or anything of the
sort that that though that's what you
want to you want to look for that and
then you want to be that you will
move in the direction of the people that
you associate with so i
it's important to associate with people
that are better than yourself and
actually the most important decision
many of you make not all of you will be
the spouse you're choosing
and
you really
you want to associate with people who
are the kind of person you'd like to be
you'll you'll move in that direction and
the most important person by far in that
respect is your spouse
i can't overemphasize how important that
is and you're right
the friends you have
uh
they will form you as you go
through life and
uh
make some good friends keep them for the
rest of your life but have them be
people that you admire as well as like i
was very lucky in life
uh if you tell me who your heroes are i
will
make a pretty good prediction about how
what you're going to do and i i had the
right heroes i was very lucky in life
and
my heroes never let me down and started
with my dad
and then i had others in business and
so i have had
great teachers some formal teachers some
that were just
informal teachers teachers by instinct
or example
and
if i hadn't had those
you know my life i'm sure would have
been very different if success is
contingent on a good plan excellent edu
you know education and execution in a
driven mindset
what do you think
makes businesses fall apart
when all of these factors have been met
and con
sorry go ahead some businesses are just
tough i mean a significant percentage
you know the restaurants
that open up this year are going to fail
i mean there are a lot of a lot of tough
businesses uh i've always said if you
want to be regarded as a great business
person find a great business
and uh there's a huge difference i mean
it does make a difference
i
use this analogy when i when i got out
of columbia one of my best friends was
terrific talent
and
uh
he went to work in the steel business
and he did okay
but it was the wrong business to be in
it's very important to get on the right
train i mean you want to you want to get
on a train that's going to go 90 miles
an hour and not one that's going to go
30 miles an hour and you're going to try
to figure out how to you know push it
along a little faster so it really does
make a huge difference uh and and there
are some businesses that are inherently
uh there's far more opportunity and than
others so you want to give a lot of
thought to what train you're getting on
and
uh i owned a half interest
when i was i don't know 21 or 22 in a
service station uh a sinclair service
station with a power mine in the
national guard it was a lousy business
you know we had a guy right next to us
he kept selling more gallons of gas that
we did he would cut our prices and
everything i mean i i don't i don't care
if you know if you're a combination of
steve jobs and larry ellison and
everyone else you're not going to
succeed if you got a guy selling gas
below costs next year so you know what
it's important to get on the right train
one of the best ways for youth to get
started now in securing their financial
future
uh for
for what to secure their financial
future
for you youth oh well it's not it's not
very complicated uh
it goes back
to getting full use out of your own
talents first
i mean the difference between whether
you're going to be earning x or 2x or 3x
a year
uh 20 years from now
[Music]
is going to be a function
of how well not how much talent you have
but how how well you use the talents you
already have
and
so that is
the your best financial future
is your own ability and and
and your
uh a capacity to
to use those abilities to their
potential
and
they can't take that can't be taken away
from you they can't even tax it i mean
you know most things if you if you wanna
you know a piece of real estate if they
double the taxes they double the taxes
and that changes your ownership in the
property because now in effect the
taxing authorities own more of it
because they've got a greater command on
the revenue stream uh the same thing
about
almost any asset you have
but
they they don't tax what's in your head
and they don't tax
your ability to
start performing when you when you get
to work in the morning and finish in the
evening uh to to your potential one of
the things that amazes me
is how people who really do perform well
just sort of jump out at you once you're
running a business when i got out of
school i thought you know everybody
would behave that way but they don't
most people sort of go
go through life in a sleepwalk and
and
if you don't
you will stand out so
the big the biggest thing for your
financial future is yourself what do you
think the lessons are of the last couple
cycles that you've seen from an investor
standpoint we've got a young a lot of
young kids out there you've lived
through multiple cycles in the
in the uh 50 60 years plus you've been
doing investing in seven years
manifesting that what are the lessons
and what you know these are young people
what should they take away
the lessons are the people will continue
to make the same mistakes they've made i
mean it
humans
and whether it doesn't correlate to iq
particularly i mean they when they get
when they get greedy
and we had this huge bubble in the most
important asset the american public has
housing i mean so you had a huge bubble
and something you could borrow heavily
against so you could run a margin
account effect on a house instead of
stocks and
and the conditions got very relaxed and
so when that bubble popped
but people came into that gradually when
they get fearful
it happens all at once i mean when
everybody wants when people get scared
they all want to leave at one time and
we had them all want to leave at one
time and we'll have that'll happen again
it'll happen with a different set of
circumstances but
but uh the human animal
uh will keep behaving pretty much the
way
it has in the past so we will have
periodic
uh
recessions will have an occasional panic
which doesn't know
all recessions don't come from panics
but uh
but the good news is
if you look at the 20th century
in the 20th century we had two world
wars we had the great depression we had
the flu epidemic we had
the cold war we had the atom bomb you
name it
the dow jones average went from 66
to 11
497.
you know with all these terrible things
happening supposedly at various times
america works and uh well i when i
bought my first stock when i was 11 that
was in the spring of 1942 and that was a
couple months after pearl harbor and we
were getting clobbered in the pacific at
corregidor and bataan i mean the death
march of baton and
in in in the european theater the blitz
of england was on and
but and the dow was at about 100
but just look at where we are now i mean
the country really works uh
the trick is
i mean
it seems to me the obligation of a
society as prosperous as ours is to
figure out how nobody gets left too far
behind but you don't have to worry about
the system working but you will have
you will have periodic recessions and
you will have an occasional
panic brought on by something that who
knows where it comes from you know
and
uh the thing to remember at that time i
wrote an op-ed piece in in the new york
times and
in the fall of 2008 and i said you know
that
that the the country will come back you
know it'll go through a big recession
and everything but it'll come back and
it's coming back
hi
this is nice to meet you
pleasure to meet you
so they're looking at this very pretty
necklace here
so i don't know if you want to give a
crazy foreign price on that i give a
crazy warm price on everything of course
all right
very good thank you so much i think
this might be something more interesting
it might be more interesting take a look
what do you think of that
oh my gosh
wow
i love it well i think you want to try
it on
you make me so happy
and i want to make you happy for the
rest of our lives oh my god yes will you
marry me of course i will
oh thank you
oh my gosh i'm getting all hurry over
here
yeah it was a total chance
thank you okay
okay
good things happen to more shots
thank you
where does this populist instinct in you
come from
i was born lucky you know i was born in
the united states of america the odds
were at least 30 to 1 against that i
didn't have anything to do with that i
was born wild for capitalization i
didn't have anything to do with that so
here i am i won the ovarian lottery the
day i was born you know a lot of people
don't
you know they go off to afghanistan and
fight for us to preserve things for me i
mean i i when some of my friends
complain about their taxes i feel like
saying let's continue this conversation
on the shores of normandy you know let's
just go over there and we'll just talk
about this
how terrible your situation is and i i
really think this country
works wonderfully on a market system and
we don't want to give it up it needs we
have to control that market system in
many ways but
it works it works with the kind of
incentives we have it works with
equality of opportunity it's not perfect
but we've tried it we tried for it all
the time
but
the lucky ones still
prosper incredibly disproportionately
you know under this i'm not for having
some kind of bizarre wine besides what's
proper for everybody but i do think
something that thinks about the 60
million people that are living at 21 000
a year or less in their household i
think i think a rich rich rich society
should think about them a little bit
every day you've been famous for your
investment strategy on uh basically that
follows the opposite side that
principals invest when the chips are
down and right
um
that served you well so what's your
favorite your favorite uh time that you
were able to accomplish that when you
caught somebody down and
and uh well i i i always think my
favorite time is gonna be tomorrow you
know
but i
it it's it's always been fun you know
and uh
there's a company here in
in washington called geico you know and
i i first got exposed to that in 1950 i
was
i was 20 years i was 19 years old it was
51 i'm sorry i was 20 years old and
i came down here and
and i came down on a saturday
because i'd learned that my
professor who i worshipped at columbia
named ben graham was the chairman i got
down here and the door was locked when i
went to the building because it was
saturday and i pounded on the door and
some janitor let me in and a marvelous
fellow named laura davidson
spent four hours with me teaching me all
about insurance and he
he helped me so much in life you're
gonna get
you're gonna get help by some wonderful
people in life it's it's a great thing
to to remember later on when you have to
be my age that you know all the help
you've received from different people
because
uh nobody does it alone obama got in
trouble when he said that in the
campaign that you know nobody does it by
themselves nobody does do it by
themselves we all sit
in the shade of trees that were planted
by others so it's obligatory i think to
plant a few trees ourselves if we've had
good luck uh
it's
it's been a great ride but it's not over
would i be wrong to suggest the thing
you worry most about is whether after
you are gone that that culture remains
as it is that you have in a sense
made berkshire strong enough to exist
without you yeah i don't worry about
that i worried about it over the years
which is why i did a bunch of things
that i think
uh ensure that future but i uh
there's that's always the question i
mean you you know you've seen all kinds
of
great companies topple from you once
said to me and to others um you have to
make your company idiot-proof because at
some point some idiot will run it yeah
well that may be even the case now i
mean
but if someone has said i think
that the thing you worry most about is
whether berkshire will be intact 20
years after years well i don't worry
about but i care about it yeah no i and
since i care about it
i
i've put things in place which i think
almost ensure that that berkshire will
be a lot better 20 years after i'm gone
than than it is now are there
investments that you really wish you had
never done what's your worst investment
i made a lot of terrible deals
and
the worst
it's it's hard to probably the worst
you'll be when i make in the future but
the uh the current
title i i bought a company and and
instantly i did it i mean we do not have
uh powerpoints around or people
explaining this stuff to me i just go
out and do them and
we bought a company
uh called dexter's shoe george
mitchell's here tonight he knows the
company and we paid
400 million dollars for it
uh which went to zero but we paid 400
million in stock and the stock we gave
up is probably worth maybe three or four
billion today so whenever berkshire goes
down i feel better about that deal you
know why why get involved with something
with the decisions every day are
are terrible when you can get into a
business where they're very very easy
it's much more fun to sell coca-cola and
everybody's smiling as my partner
charlie marker says wait we haven't
learned how to make a silk purse out of
a sow's ear we have enough trouble
making silk purse out of silk you
famously passed on intel when it was
getting started i thought and
i knew bob bob noyce pretty well and we
bought it
we bought the converts
when they were private they were just uh
because of bob we bought them at
grinnell college and and the endowment
of grinnell college went from 8 million
to a billion dollars in about
12 or 14 years so and it took intel was
a help on that but i
you know
in the end
i don't worry about things i don't
understand i mean i think it was tom
watson senior said i'm no genius but i'm
smart in spots and i stay around those
spots you know and that
there's a lot to that and knowing your
circle of competence is
where that perimeter is enormously
important and you know the fact that
there are all kinds of things i can't do
and there's plenty of companies i can't
analyze but i don't have to worry about
that you have said before uh that to me
and to others that berkshire is your
canvas that you paint on
uh it's your masterpiece but i don't
like masterpieces but it's my campus
so what what is it that if you look at
it today berkshire
you find fault with blindfold with yeah
well i i made plenty of mistakes along
the way so i've got a lot of brush
strokes out there that if i just give me
a little whatever it takes to remove
that i would do it so i i made plenty of
mistakes but i expect to make mistakes
and i'll keep making mistakes because
unless you take chances you won't make
mistakes oh sure and then and mistakes
are part of the game i mean they're
swinging at pitches and you miss a few
but
no i i i i don't want to sound
i feel good about berkshire i mean i
the people i'm associated with the
businesses
the
we have a
a per we lay out our economic principles
and i laid them out many many years ago
and we don't change them i mean we we we
we try to operate that way it doesn't
mean we're perfection you get a company
of 260 000 people i'll guarantee right
now somebody's doing something i wish
they weren't i mean you can't have a
city of 260 000 people don't have no
jails but but
overall i feel there's a
a culture
that i don't think any other large
really large public company has and i
think it's enduring because it's so
inculcated and the the managers the
shareholders the correctors everybody so
i i i feel good about berkshire of the
investments you've made over the years
at berkshire hathaway which one would
you say was the single best investment
is there one that you really are most
proud of
well
the one i'm probably the most
emotionally attached to is geico because
of
a bunch of reasons but it goes back
to
a day in january of 1951 a saturday and
and
that
what lorimer davidson did for me
changed my life and he didn't have to do
it i mean i walked in there as some 20
year old kid on a saturday and he he
spent four hours
educating me and then he became a friend
for life and then
subsequent people are jack byrne and and
tony nicely who's here tonight i mean
it's it's it's just been a wonderful
association whether we made any money or
not but
we've done pretty well on the investment
too but it
beyond that it it it has a special
meaning to me the whole long-term
capital management i hope most of you
are familiar with it but the whole story
is really
fascinating because
if you take john merriweather
and eric rosenfeld
larry hillenbrand gregg hawkins
victor ghani
the two nobel prize winners and merton
shoals if you take the 16 of them
that they probably have as high an
average iq as any 16 people working
together in one business in the country
including at microsoft or wherever you
want to name
so that incredible amount of intellect
in that room
now you combine that with the fact
that those 16 had had extensive
experience in the field they were
operating i mean this this one was not a
bunch of guys who had
made their money you know selling men's
clothing and then all of a sudden went
into the securities business or anything
they had
they they'd had in aggregate the 16 that
probably had 350 or 400 years of
experience doing exactly what they were
doing
and then you throw in the third factor
that most of them had virtually all of
their very substantial net worths in the
business so they had their own money up
hundreds and hundreds of millions of
dollars of their own money up
super high intellect working in a field
they knew
and essentially they went broke
and that to me is absolutely fascinating
i mean i i if i ever write a book it's
going to be called why smart people do
dumb things
my partner says it should be
autobiographical but i
but this might be an interesting
illustration and these are perfectly
decent guys i you know i i i respect
them and they helped me out when i was i
had problems with solomon and so they
they're they're not bad people at all
but
to make the money they didn't have and
didn't need they risked what they did
have and did need
and that's foolish that is just plain
foolish i didn't make any switcher iq is
if you if you risk something that is
important to you
for something that is unimportant to you
it just does not make any sense i don't
care whether the odds are 100 the one
that you succeed or a thousand one to
succeed if you hand me a gun
with a thousand chambers a million
chambers in it and there's a bullet in
one chamber and you said put it up your
temple how much do you want to be paid
to pull it once
i'm not going to pull it you know you
can name any sum you want but it doesn't
do anything for me on the upside and i
think the downside's fairly clear
so i'm not interested in that kind of a
game and yet people do it
financially then without thinking about
it very much
avoid credit cards just forget about
them
uh we're in various businesses that
issue credit cards the american public
loves credit cards but if you start
revolving debt on credit cards you're
going to be paying
uh 18 or 20
and
you can't make
progress in your financial life going
around borrowing money at 18 or 20
percent
you can make a lot of money by lending
it out at 18 or 20 over time you know if
you can find anybody that's good that
will borrow from you but you don't want
to be on the side of the equation that's
always behind in life
uh
you know i was lucky i'd saved about ten
thousand dollars by the time i got out
of school that ten thousand dollars was
really worth millions i might have
earned later on because after you get a
family and everything the expenses roll
in but but those were my tools to work
with but it was only because i was ahead
of the game if you're behind the game by
ten thousand dollars at some point and
paying eighteen or twenty percent
interest on it you will never you know
you'll never get out of it so the trick
i've got a partner that says
all i want to know is where i'm going to
die so i'll never go there you know and
uh
and that's true in financial matters as
well you want to figure out where you
don't want to be
uh ahead of time and avoid that and i
get about a dozen letters a day from
people who are having terrible problems
and there are two reasons why they have
terrible problems one is
a number of them have had health
problems of some sort i mean they have
really been hit by some or somebody in
their family has been hit by some kind
of catastrophic
illness and that is a you know it's a
terrible thing to happen to any family
and they get in
they run up bills they can't pay and and
really only society can solve that one
uh
uh in terms of protecting people against
that that's just plain bad luck
but
the other one is from people who run up
credit card debt and uh they're facing
bankruptcy or they've been through
bankruptcy once before and they owe a
whole bunch of money and they can't they
can't even pay the interest level and
pay any principle
and half of my letters come from people
like that and that that that problem is
avoidable catastrophic illness is not
but but
credit card debt is something you bring
on yourself and
it's way better
it's way easier to stay out of trouble
than to get out of trouble financially
and and uh i will guarantee you if you
run a big credit card that you will be
in trouble
uh probably the rest of your life in
terms of
uh your financial situation on the other
hand if you get ahead of the game
uh
even it's on a very modest scale
so that money is coming in from
investing
and you're you're
people owe you money or equities owe you
ownership
you'll be way out of the game compared
to paying it
being always being paying
your creditors every month so
my advice to you is
if you can't pay for it don't buy it and
get yourself in a position where you can
pay for anything and then we'll be glad
to see you at borsheims or the nebraska
furniture market
i was wondering how you define success
personally
well i
i can certainly define happiness because
that's what that's what i am i mean i i
if that if that
i mean i get to do what i like to do
every single day of the year and i get
to do it with people i like
and i get to the i get
i don't have to associate with anybody
causes my stomach to churn
and
uh the only thing in my job i don't like
and this only happens about every three
or four years occasionally i have to
fire somebody and i don't like that's
the only thing other than i tap dance to
work and i get down there and i think
i'm supposed to lie on my back and paint
the ceiling you know or something like
microwaves i mean that's the way i feel
and
and it it it doesn't diminish it it's
it's tremendous fun so
uh
you know if
uh they say that uh
success is uh uh uh getting what you
want and happiness is wanting what you
get well i don't know which one
applies in this case but i i do know
that i i wouldn't be doing anything else
i mean
uh i do advise you you know and when you
go out to work go go to work for an
organization that you admire
people you admire because it'll it'll
it'll turn you on and and
you ought to be happy where you are
working and i always worry about people
who
say you know i'm going to do this for 10
years i really don't like it very well
then i'll do 10 more years of this
investment i mean that's a little like
saving up sex for your old age i mean
not a very good idea
so get right in you got to recommend
that get right get right
get right into what you enjoy you know
and and
and you'll be successful at it you
really will i mean you won't be able to
miss and uh
um
you know that's uh
i don't regard what i do as the most
important thing in the world at all but
it's right for me i mean i happen to be
wired in a certain way that what i do
works in this if i had to do
what
you know bill does i mean it lasts about
10 minutes
and
that's true a lot of things but i
luckily i kind of stumbled into the
thing that i i do best and and that you
know that it's worked out well so i want
a simple business easy to understand
great economics now honest enable
management
and and
then i can see about in a general way
where they're going to be ten years from
now and if i can't see whether to be ten
years now i don't want to buy it
basically i don't want to buy any stock
where if they close the new york stock
exchange tomorrow for five years i won't
be happy owning it
i buy a farm and i don't get a coat on
it for five years and i'm happy if the
farm does okay you know i buy an
apartment house don't get a quote on it
for five years i'm happy if the
apartment house produces the returns
that i expect but people buy a stock and
they look at the price the next morning
and they decide whether they're doing
well or not doing well it's crazy
because they're buying a piece of a
business that's what graham the most
fundamental part of what he taught me
you know you're not buying a stock
you're buying you're buying a part
ownership in a business you will do well
if the business does well and if you
didn't pay a totally silly price and
that's what it's all about and you ought
to buy businesses you understand just
like if you're buying farms you ought to
buy farms you understand
it
it's not complicated i always look at iq
and and talent as sort of
representing the
the horsepower of the motor but then in
terms of the output the efficiency which
the motor works that depends on
rationality because a lot of people
start out with 400 horsepower motors and
get 100 horsepower of output and
it's way better to have a 200 horsepower
motor and get it all into output and so
why do why do smart people do things
that interfere with
really getting the the output they're
entitled to and it's uh
it gets into
the habits and the character into
temperament and it really gets into
behaving in a rational manner it's not
letting not getting in your own way
as i say everybody here has the
ability
absolutely to do anything i do and and
much beyond
and and some of you will and some of you
won't but it it
it will the ones that won't it will
because because
uh you get your own way it won't because
the the world doesn't allow you to it
will be because you don't allow yourself
to because you made it this far in a
video i want to celebrate you most
people start and don't finish most
people never actually follow through
most people say they want something but
they don't ever do the work to actually
get it but you're different you are
special believe nation you made it here
all the way to the end and i love you so
it's a special celebration if you put a
hashtag believe down in the comments
below on this video i will showcase you
and celebrate you somewhere on the
screen in a future video because you are
awesome if you want to watch the world's
best investors share their best advice
check the video right there next to me i
think you'll love it continue to believe
and i'll see you there i will never buy
a stock in my life that doesn't pay a
dividend if it's not returning cash to
me it's a speculation and in investing
i'm in a no called strike business which
is the best business you can be